rassurez vous je vous en prie c'est à
viroflay que ça i guess mais a conduit
son taxi ce jour là objectif récupérer
un patient pour l'emmener à la clinique
de l'europe au port marly c'est ce qu'on
appelle le transport médicalisé en taxi
médical isis sous-entendent que c'est un
taxi conventionné
donc en fait on est sous la convention
de la sécurité sociale et donc on répond
à un cahier des charges à des critères
bien précis plus une enquête de moralité
et à partir de là on peut prétendre à
faire du taxi conventionné
c'est à dire à transporter des gens pour
certains soins bien précis pour
bénéficier de ce transport il faut une
prescription médicale et remplir
certaines conditions
pour christian sa dialyse rentrer dans
ce dispositif moi c'est un traitement
comptable de longue durée la clinique
remplie de bons profs le bon de
transport en indiquant l'heure de prise
en compte chez moi d'un à viroflay et
puis leur
normalement de la prison en compte le
soir à la clinique le traitement de
christian nécessite plusieurs trajets
par semaine allers et retours entre son
domicile et la clinique grâce au
transport médicalisé en taxi cela ne lui
coûte rien une manière aussi de créer du
lien social pas beaucoup avec la
personne compte tenu du fait que je
viens de pratiquement trois fois par
semaine
azur comme un inconnu
autant se connaître un peu les taxis
conventionnés eux sont rémunérés par la
sécurité sociale avec la crise sanitaire
ce mode de transport représente
aujourd'hui une part non négligeable de
leurs activités
la tabbee d'accord l'avare entendu